almost 60 000 people have died from
covid-19 in China in the past five weeks
that's according to new data released on
Saturday it's a huge increase from
previous figures and health officials
say the elderly has been hit the hardest
it's really ill patients are mainly
elderly people with the oldest being 105
the average age 75 and a half and those
age 60 and above accounting for 89.6
percent of the cases it's also common
for them to have a variety of underlying
diseases
the World Health Organization in several
countries have accused China of
under-representing the scale of the
outbreak
early last month Beijing abruptly lifted
its zero covert policy after almost
three years
hospitals Nationwide were overwhelmed
and medical staff under enormous
pressure including American doctor
Howard Bernstein everything was just
completely
clogged up you know the emergency room
was full every bed was full the waiting
room was full waiting and to get to the
emergency room the theater Clinic was
full and then all the ICU and hospital
beds were taken
previously only people who died from
coronavirus induced respiratory failure
were included in the official death toll
now those who died of the virus in
combination with other illnesses are
being counted the government says the
number of people being treated in Fever
clinics like these peaked in late
December but that number has now
declined by about 80 percent
Dr Bernstein says his hospital is no
longer crowded but the outbreak is far
from over
there was a sort of you know shocking
amount of illness and degree of illness
and
um and now
now we're dealing with a different
covid phenomena
which uh you know which I'm identifying
is people who are ill in December who
have still
do not feel like they've come
millions of Chinese are traveling from
cities to remote regions in the lead up
to the Lunar New Year movement that's
expected to cause a surge in infections
authorities are focusing on improving
medical facilities and access to
medicines in rural areas
International Health experts have
welcomed the new data but as the figures
only include those who died in hospital
they say the true death toll could be
much higher
training you Al Jazeera Beijing